DAN GALPIN: A nightmare
for any Android developer
involves losing
their app signing key
or having their app
signing key compromised.
Losing this key prevents you
from updating your published
app, while a
compromised key allows
others to potentially
leverage your identity
for malicious intent.
Since the security
provided by this signature
is integrated into the Android
platform, once the key is lost,
little can be done.
That means that developers
have traditionally
been responsible for keeping
their private signing
key both safe and accessible.
But now you can let
Google Play sign apps
and manage your keys for you
in the Google Play Console.
Let's go through the app signing
process with an existing app.
After selecting one of your
apps in the Play Console,
App Signing is available under
the Release Management tools
section.
After accepting the
terms of service,
you will see the
App Signing page
with details about how
it works and instructions
on how to start using
it with your app.
If you store your key
in a Java KeyStore,
the first step is to
download the PEPK tool.
You use the PEPK tool along with
the command given in the Play
Console to create an encrypted
version of your signing key.
If you aren't using
a Java KeyStore,
we also have instructions for
how to encrypt your signing
key from a plain text PEM file.
Then you upload the
encrypted key file
to Google Play using
the Play Console.
Now that Google Play
has your signing key,
you have to generate
a new upload key
and register the
public key certificate
for this key with Google.
The detailed key tool
command to do this
can be found under
the App Signing page.
Then you upload
both key files using
the Play Console in a
single, secure transaction.
After uploading the required
keys and certificate,
click Enroll.
If everything is OK,
you'll see a page
with deployment and
upload certificates.
And when managing
your release, you
will see a green
check on App Signing,
indicating that it is enabled.
For a new app, you
can choose to have
Google generate the signing key
so the process is much simpler.
We highly recommend you use
App Signing to sign new apps.
After enrolling in
App Signing, you
will use the upload key to sign
all future updates to your app.
Google Play uses the upload
key to verify your identity
and will then sign your app with
the original app signing key.
That newly signed app will
be delivered to users.
You may ask, but I'm still
having to sign with a key?
What happens if I lose this key
or this key gets compromised?
No problem.
We can revoke the
key immediately,
as it is used to verify
your identity with Google,
but isn't part of the Android
Platform Security model.
To have your current
upload key revoked,
you can contact
Google Play support
through a web support form.
So when you use App
Signing, losing your key
doesn't mean that you can't
update your app anymore.
With a simple process, you
can generate a new upload key
and provide us with
its certificate
so you can continue
updating your app.
Access the Play Console
to enroll your application
and take advantage
of App Signing today.
For more details, check
out the documentation.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]